Is it our community that don't have healthcare?
I know I've,
I've,
I didn't have healthcare forever.
Go.
Yeah,
I got it a week ago and I booked all the appointments.
Did you?
Everything.
I got the kitty cat checked,
got the teeth checked.
[inaudible] eyes were you worry about the TT.
You ever,
if you have the feeling like you have a cavity,
like a phantom cavity,
like shit,
I lost my tooth hurt.
Talk about fucking cavity.
I definitely did.
My teeth were like crevasses.
O j a bunch of cab.
Yeah,
she filled me like four times cause I haven't been because healthcare is
ridiculous.
No,
I wasn't eating candy.
You got all these holes in your face.
I don't know.
I think like,
you know,
changes in my life.
Maybe I got ringworm from you change
two changes.
Yeah.
Little kids get it all the time.
They do.
Oh dude to they're rolling in dirt.
I'm going to blow you away.
Blow your mind away.
Okay.
Hookworm is super common in the south and it literally diminishes your capacity
for thinking.
So like the idea of like to slack jawed southern dumb person Theo.
No,
no,
I'm sorry.
I didn't know she was going to do that.
I would never have her on Joe.
You know,
I love you.
I love you feel no not,
but maybe people feel knows relative.
If you had to say the field gone voice like maybe a few people that I know.
Yes.
Yeah.
There were all hookworm uh,
victims.
What,
so how do you get hookworm walking around barefoot?
I mean,
there's just too many opportunities to get these worms in your body.
Oh,
for sure.
That's so gross.
When you see dudes who go to like some foreign country and they get scratched
and they come back in a Bot,
flies clone other ED and their belly.
Yeah.
A kid just died recently in India,
I think it was India.
He got a infection.
He was having headaches and it turns out worms from pig feces had,
they made it all the way up into his brain and they were making cysts all
throughout his brain.
Yeah.
Shortly thereafter it they said there was so bad they couldn't even give him
deworming medication because if they did,
they were worried his brain would start bleeding.
And then you know it would suffer from a stroke.
What?
I am not going to sleep tonight all as warm talk.
What is the [inaudible] to cirrhosis?
Pull those pictures out to find the pictures.
Yeah,
pictures of the dudes brain.
It's just like filled with sis.
Oh God.
Why are we looking at,
cause we're high and it's like 10 in the morning.
Oh you know what I was saying before I forgot to bring my fanny pack.
You.
You gave me one of your fanny packs and I travel with it everywhere.
Thank you very much.
I'm glad you enjoy it.
Trying to spread the word source.
Whole thing ever.
This is my fanny pack.
I know I can wear this for middle.
Same One.
A couple people have talked some shit and I was like,
you better step back,
step back,
step back.
I've got my pharmacy in there.
I've got my whole thing so I can be a doctor.
The road,
you have a stethoscope.
I got a scalpel.
What's up?
He,
he complained of having pain in his groin and swelling in his eye,
and then they found out he had cysts all over his brain.
I mean,
I have pain in my groin every week,
but
look at his brain on the right,
I'm assuming as a result,
both of them as different views of both different views.
Those little holes are all cysts inside of bronc.
Yeah.
He's brain is literally imploding.
Although those little spots,
those little white spots,
those are all little cysts inside his brain.
That must've been painful.
Fucking pure agony.
It must be pure agony.
This was in India,
you said?
What country,
man?
Most of India.
Yeah.
Aw,
fuck that in.
Just imagine like people having,
not the access to healthcare in this country,
but at least we're a little bit modernized.
Being in one of those countries and being poor.
You're fucked.
You're so fucked.
By swallowing microscopic eggs passed in the feces of a person who has
intestinal pork.
Tapeworm I never go to brunch again,
but think about that.
It's not even just pork tapeworm.
It's the eggs in the shit of a person who has the tape.
Did you see what God,
Jesus Christ Holy Hell is get in your mouth and shit.
I smoked a joint before this shit.
I am in a pure panic attack.
Don't eat ass in India unless that person is not anti tape worm medication.
Also never eat ass again.
I mean this is a PSA for antiacid eating.
It is.
I told you I had a cool I a few weeks ago.
That was my life will be Saint Jamie
the,
there's been a change in the way that the pork industry is going to be doing
inspections that the government's going to stop doing it apparently as of like
early May and the industry is now taking over.
Oh,
that'll be,
that's a terrible idea here.
It's just that's exactly what you want.
This is one of those things where people that are all in favor of deregulating
everything.
You need to understand this shit like this happens.
If these people cut corners and we know people have cut corners before and maybe
it's not all of them.
Maybe most of them are going to be great.
People are going to die or get sick.
They're going to get ECO law.
They're going to get all sorts of fucked up things,
40% and replacing them with employees,
cutting the number of federal inspectors by about 40% that is such a bad idea.
It looks like America and everywhere is going to get a whole bunch of hookworms.
This is like having the mafia police,
the streets taking away.
There'll be no limits on slaughter line speeds.
Oh,
that is so gross.
No one's trying to make it quick.